les dernières 24 heures ont été
particulièrement meurtrières en europe
le vieux continent compte aujourd'hui
plus de 200 mille cas confirmés pays le
plus touché l'italie la botte déplorent
le plus de morts dans le monde et voit
son bilan quotidien repartir à la hausse
après deux jours de baisse
743 morts en 24 heures la contagion
semble tout de même se ralentir avec une
hausse de 8 % des cas soit près de 70
milles au total il s'agit là de l'un des
plus faibles taux depuis l'arrivée de la
pandémie dans le pays elle face à la
crise les syndicats de métallurgie et
chimie menacent de faire grève en cause
le manque de protection des ouvriers
écoutez à ce propos le premier ministre
du cpnt mon souhait est qu'il n'y ait
aucune grève et nous ne pouvons pas nous
permettre d'avoir une grève en ce moment
je dis cela par rapport aux stations
essence
je suis convaincu que ces menaces de
grève seront retirés car nous devons
évidemment garantir à l'ensemble de la
communauté nationale les services
essentiels
par conséquent je peux garantir que la
chaîne d'approvisionnement en denrées
alimentaires et en carburant sera
assurée